i really want to start the interview off
with the most important thing is max
part of a government program to see how
fast someone can grow in such a short
period of time
we've been doing experiments on him
well we've actually been shooting the
show for almost five years
so
it probably seems like not as long as it
is but he is tall he got really tall
well between the second and third season
he grew six feet
you know
let's be honest but anyway let me let me
be serious um
when you guys all first got involved i
am curious how much did the writers and
everybody tell you ultimately what the
arc is gonna be and how much was it sort
of like we have an idea
we'll figure it out as we go
i mean my recollection of the very first
season is that they actually had seven
or eight scripts fully written and we
sat down and read them all together in a
over the course of an afternoon or two
which is
actually incredibly rare on a tv show
you know they might give you some
ideas but it's very very rare that
you're seeing that many scripts up front
um
so i feel like they've been these
writers are actually really open about
about story and and the directions that
they're having they they do at the very
end there's always sort of you know
the final episodes seem to kind of take
take longer but they're good they're
good at beginnings
so this is obviously the third and final
season and for each of you guys i am
curious when you put this much time into
something what is it like on the last
day of set are you emotional like could
you sort of maybe talk about what it was
like and i am curious if you
hypothetically borrowed anything from
set with obviously the intention of
returning it
it's actually quite surreal i think any
job when it comes to an end when you've
been working with a group of people
in this kind of intense way and
it comes to an end it's always quite
surreal because you're slightly out of
body kind of going this is it this is
the end i'm not going to see these
people this is the end of this project
this is the end of you know
and so the last day is always a bit of a
i think there's always an anti-climax to
it as well because i think you want it
to be this great thing and often it's
just not what you know it's so weird um
and it's only later
when you
uh when you
when you've finished it it's about a
week later that it sinks in that it's
over and actually
you know it's it's always quite
it's mostly quite sad because you know
you you forged these great relationships
specifically and particularly with this
one you know i i did feel quite sad
afterwards because you know it's been a
real ride making this
yeah yeah the last day was kind of
was very strange because all of a sudden
we were on this
you know we're on this uh we're going
100 miles an hour and then we stop
to say
this is it
and it all hit
and then i got in my truck
not even i had already packed everything
i got in my truck and started driving
back across the border at
7 00 pm and in the
snow and it's like all right bye done
there was no
there was no let's have dinner there was
nothing
i got out of the suit and got in my
truck which was already packed up and i
left from set
because we were shooting during covet
you know we were we started shooting
in late august which was
really
we were one of the first shows to come
back after the initial sort of few
months of the pandemic and
so it was a difficult season to shoot
and in some ways by the time you know we
shot that last day on
december 23rd
you know we knew that
the uk was closing the borders toby
needed to get home hadn't been home in
five months and get home for christmas
to see his kids and ignacio was trying
to you know so it was there was a there
was a lot going on right at the end but
there really was this sense that um
we
you know we made it through this
this really difficult
season of covid and working
uh one of the things about lost in space
is it never slows down each episode just
the the momentum just keeps going um for
you guys what do you want to tease fans
about the final eight i'm not i think
it's eight episodes or is it ten
episodes eight yeah so the final eight
episodes
i i think that um
[Music]
you know that uh they've never been
tested like this before and there's
um there's a lot of uh evidence to
suggest they might all
they might not
make it
that's pretty sad
but it's that tough it's that it's that
intense and it's that
yeah yeah
it was kind of uh
yeah it was kind of uh
i guess at the beginning when we were in
the early episodes when we were
having to play those scenes i was like
oh wow
it was we've never experienced that
before i mean we've always been in the
danger and everything but there was
always a solution
so uh those scenes of
uh-oh
yeah no answers that was really the the
you know this season three starts and
we've sent the kids off on
all the all the children from from
all the colonists kids we sent off at
the end of episode two to try to save
them and
us adults are sort of left behind we
don't have an alien engine we cannot get
to alpha centauri we're stuck in this
sort of
robot
world um
and there's no there's there's seemingly
no solution so for
for maureen who's had you know her
you know her her thing is there's a
there's always an answer there's always
a solution and in fact there isn't and
this sort of sense of just
um
failure that i think this season starts
with
gives us a lot of of room
to to to to grow
yeah i think it's um i i the the start
of this season is really
um
kind of great because i mean look
there's an element to this
it's rather like um i don't know there's
those cyclical films where you know like
i don't know james bond where you know
that you know you know you know that
he's gonna
he's there's gonna be another one but
you're tricking the audience into
believing like it's not gonna happen
he's gonna die you know and like you
want that sense of jeopardy and i think
with the with this last season it's
great that it starts in this place where
you really do think things are hopeless
and you know the the
john and maureen have always been
defined by in this show by their kids
and by their family and how they are
together and they don't have that
anymore and what does that mean that
they are and if they can't be together
then what's going to happen to their
kids and the kids are on a different
jack where they're trying to desperately
survive
and there's just this constant um
you know there's this constant sense of
like they're just not gonna make it and
they'll you know and you wanna you want
an audience to believe that that
the stakes are really really high and
that people could die and you know
and most importantly like uh toby
said uh it's important to remind people
that
he was in a bond film i think that's
what he tried to do he was trying to fly
that's what i got out of the whole thing
he was trying to remind people
listen it was such a great song
subtle plug subtle plug
it was great the movie yeah the movie
needed the plug it's back in the 90s
there is something that happens towards
the end of this season that is utterly
utterly surprising
i've only seen the first four episodes
of uh season three it's gonna be that i
don't think anyone's gonna see coming
now now i'm very now i'm very curious
listen i i love learning about the
behind the scenes of the making of shows
for fans of lost in space is there
anything that you think would like
surprise them to learn about the making
of the show
one of the things that surprised me when
we started and certainly throughout the
first couple of seasons is how much we
shot on location so you know when i when
i when they first approached
me about the project somehow in my mind
i was like we're going to be we're going
to be in a studio we're going to be you
know on a set it's all going to be a lot
of green screen and in fact
um it's been a
there is some of that for sure but we
we have been out in the elements
throughout this show you know the first
the first season we spent on a
mountaintop uh in the rain and snow
second season we shot in iceland
they're they're being um
yeah that was something that surprised
me
i think they'll be surprised that uh
the chicken was voiced by morgan freeman
it was not easy to get him but
[Laughter]
didn't see that answer coming honestly
i'll leave it there and just say i've
really enjoyed the series and thank you
for giving me your time uh good luck
with the rest of your speed dating today
thank you
you